[Música]
buen día a todos y bienvenidos a la
entrevista de France 24 nuestra invitada
de hoy es la directora general de la
UNESCO Gracias por estar con nosotros
Buenos días Gracias Nos encontramos en
delfos Grecia con motivo del aniversario
50 de la convención sobre el patrimonio
mundial adoptada en 1972
delfos es un símbolo según la mitología
griega es aquí donde se creó el ombligo
del mundo un lugar que también Encarna
el espíritu de esta convención sobre el
patrimonio mundial con motivo de estos
50 años
en primer lugar es cierto que es una
oportunidad maravillosa poder celebrar
en delfos en este magnífico lugar que
tiene una tradición de encuentros
filosóficos y culturales y un espíritu
de paz con todos los dioses de la
mitología que velan por esta cuna es
maravilloso poder celebrarlo aquí
estamos Celebrando los 50 años de un
texto que nació en París en noviembre de
1972 con la idea innovadora de tener
normas comunes para la comunidad
internacional para la protección del
patrimonio
nacional por la protección de patrimonio
la UNESCO como saben nació mucho antes
justo después de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial sobre las cenizas morales y
físicas de esta con la idea de defender
la paz a través de la cultura la
educación la ciencia y la libertad de
información claro
[Música]
la idea del patrimonio al principio no
fue la primera y poco a poco
imponiéndose con grandes éxitos en su
momento
por ejemplo para preservar los templos
de Abu simbel y los demás que había en
Nubia incluso antes de que existiera la
convención o para proteger la laguna de
Venecia antes
y en 1972 se produjo ese momento
fundacional en el que los estados se
reunieron Y decidieron comprometerse a
proteger el patrimonio mundial Entonces
desde luego en 50 años es esa lista del
patrimonio mundial que ha tenido un
éxito extraordinario pero es también y
sobre todo un derecho unas normas unos
mecanismos nacionales de protección que
nacieron y también un éxito universal
ya que 194 estados han ratificado esta
convención y se han comprometido por
tanto a conocer este patrimonio a
estudiar los científicamente y sobre
todo a protegerlo y transmitirlo
Cómo responde a esas críticas que se
escuchan habitualmente sobre la etiqueta
de patrimonio mundial
en concreto una etiqueta de patrimonio
mundial no es solo una bonita placa
decorativa que se exhibe la entrada de
un sitio reconocido
definitivamente no es eso es cierto que
algunos sitios son víctimas del turismo
excesivo Este es un problema importante
que deteriore los sitios del patrimonio
mundial y por eso nos comprometemos a
ayudar a los Estados a tener estrategias
en primer lugar para diversificar su
turismo pero también para tener una
gestión más sostenible
esto puede ser a través de entradas con
horarios
puede ser limitado el número de
visitantes en un sitio hay muchas
maneras de hacerlo puede ser como en
Venecia donde después de años de
discusión por fin logramos que los
megacruceros dejaran de atracar en la
laguna
pero en realidad
se trata de un problema que no debe
quedar oculto por la amplitud de los
éxitos que es precisamente ese
compromiso de conservar a veces de
reconstruir o rehabilitar pienso Por
ejemplo en los templos de ancor en
Camboya
templos que habían sido minados
literalmente y destruidos por la guerra
y que fueron reconstruidos gracias a la
cooperación internacional que permite
esta convención sobre el patrimonio
mundial También hay lugares que renacen
gracias a esta convención y por tanto
vuelven a ser accesibles para las
generaciones futuras es también el mismo
espíritu que nos llevó más recientemente
a poner en marcha una gran operación
para la ciudad vieja de moszul que
también fue destruida por años de guerra
que quedó en ruinas tras la ocupación
por parte del estado islámico y para la
que tenemos una gran operación
auspiciada por la UNESCO para
reconstruir la ciudad vieja las
residencias históricas la gran mezquita
simb desde la cual el estado islámico
había estado su bandera negra pero
también las iglesias los edificios y
también para reactivar la vida cultural
y en este sentido el gobierno iraquí en
la dinámica de esta reconstrucción quiso
incluir a musul en la lista de su
patrimonio nacional en su lista
indicativa nacional
entonces podemos ver que también es una
dinámica de protección conocimiento y
transmisión pero es absolutamente
necesario gestionar la cuestión del
exceso del turismo así como la cuestión
del cambio climático que también es otro
de los peligros
el cambio climático eso y la principal
amenaza para los sitios reconocidos como
patrimonio mundial usted acaba de
anunciar un plan de acción para los
próximos 50 años
cómo piensas unir este reto de
adaptación al cambio climático
lo primero que hacemos es alertar por
ejemplo hace poco publicamos un estudio
sobre los glaciares que están
desapareciendo y que están clasificados
como patrimonio mundial
de capturarlo
como lo hacen cuando los dejamos vivir y
crecer
alertamos pero también permitimos que
hayan mecanismos de gestión más
sostenibles con un turismo también más
sostenible que no sea Depredador con el
plástico o la minería cerca de los
sitios patrimonio una serie de medidas
que queremos que se adopten para
protegerlos
Pero lo primero que hay que hacer para
dejar de destruir el patrimonio mundial
es respetar los acuerdos de París y
comprometerse a reducir las emisiones de
CO2 para mantener ese calentamiento
global que consiste dentro de unos
límites que permitan la preservación Por
otra parte tenemos que comprender el
vínculo entre naturaleza y cultura
cuando destruimos el planeta cuando se
altera el clima las culturas también se
ven directamente amenazadas en su
existencias los sitios el patrimonio
inmaterial y también las prácticas
culturales y la vida de las poblaciones
locales que viven allí
África es también el continente
prioritario para la UNESCO el continente
está actualmente sobre presentado en el
patrimonio mundial representa alrededor
del 9% del total de sitios inscritos 12
países no tienen ningún sitio inscrito
como piensa lograr que África esté mejor
representada en el patrimonio mundial
Este es un gran reto que sea
cristalizado a lo largo de los años de
esta convención y nos dice algo
no es normal que después de 50 años
tengamos 27 países con ningún sitio
inscrito
entre ellos 12 en África
y para allá sobre continuación un poco
por lo tanto es absolutamente necesario
que prestemos una atención particular y
realicemos acciones concretas para
reequilibrar lo que hoy es un claro
desequilibrio geográfico
Qué tipo de acciones por ejemplo en lo
que respecta a la UNESCO hemos adoptado
por actuar por ejemplo para ayudar a
formar a Los profesionales africanos en
cuestiones de patrimonio conservación y
gestión de sitios Esto es algo que ya
empezamos a hacer pero para lo que
también intentamos movilizar a la
comunidad internacional para que nos
apoye mediante la cooperación
hay muchas peticiones de Estados
africanos y me gustaría que los
ayudáramos a preparar sus dosears de
candidatura para que en 2030 estos 12
estados puedan presentar su candidatura
al patrimonio mundial
que naturalmente tienen sitios que son
dignos de ser incluidos en esta lista
pero necesitan ser apoyados en la
preparación de los dos cierres de
candidatura en primer lugar
pero también en la gestión y la
preservación y es la vocación de la
UNESCO hacer esto también tiene la
voluntad de desarrollar nuevas formas de
patrimonio nuevos conceptos por ejemplo
paisajes naturales patrimonio Industrial
patrimonio con huella humana
de hecho la noción de patrimonio también
ha involucrado mucho en los últimos 50
años quizá teníamos una visión reducida
de lo que era el patrimonio
Pero hay toda una nueva cultura una
nueva ética del patrimonio que se ha
desarrollado con nuestros mejores
conocimientos por ejemplo el patrimonio
inmaterial Cuáles son los valores Cuáles
son las prácticas de este vínculo entre
la acción humana y los paisajes la
naturaleza pero también hay por ejemplo
formas de arquitectura
lo vimos cuando la UNESCO se movilizó
para reconstruir los mausoleos de
tombuctú en Mali esas arquitecturas
excepcionales y particulares que también
merecen ser reconocidas así que debemos
tener una visión mucho más amplia y
Universal del patrimonio
y también es importante que los expertos
que también son quienes preparan la
evaluación de los dos Sears de
candidatura tengan una experiencia más
universal
creo que también cuenta con que los
jóvenes conserven el patrimonio
es de ellos es su capital y esta es la
tragedia que estamos viviendo que es
robar el patrimonio que le pertenece a
los jóvenes si permitimos que sea
destruido por los factores que hemos
mencionado
por eso es importante que los jóvenes
sean los dueños absolutos de este
patrimonio
transmitírselo con toda la educación que
esto conlleva vamos a poner aprovecha un
dispositivo lanzado recientemente para
que las escuelas puedan disponer de
todos los recursos didácticos para
comprender y conocer mejor el patrimonio
que está cerca de los sitios del
patrimonio mundial
son plataformas digitales que permiten
otra forma de acceder a los sitios
patrimoniales y queremos hacerlas
universales
para darles a los jóvenes las claves de
un patrimonio que realmente suyo
preservarlo para las generaciones
futuras usted mencionó las nuevas
tecnologías y pretende poner la
tecnología digital al servicio de la
conservación del patrimonio mundial como
ya hace la UNESCO
pienso en particular en Ucrania o
Afganistán donde esto sucede gracias al
despliegue de satélites de estudios
cartográficos gracias a los duro nada
Es realmente un avance muy interesante
El que se está produciendo hoy en día
con las nuevas tecnologías en Ucrania
como usted lo mencio desafortunadamente
es por medio de satélites en
colaboración con otras agencias de la
ONU Aunque colaboración
que logramos monitorear de cerca los
sitios del patrimonio mundial ubicados
en Ucrania para poder evaluar los
posibles daños
o bien para monitorear otros sitios
culturales en Ucrania
pero también en Moscú los drones nos
permitieron sobrevolar sitios cuando el
destinado aún no se había realizado
en Afganistán hay un minarete que está
demasiado inclinado y estamos vigilando
su evolución mediante drones e imágenes
por satélites
así que todo esto nos da más
conocimientos más datos científicos que
son útiles para la reconstrucción para
el urbanismo para la arquitectura para
todas las profesiones vinculadas al
patrimonio cultural
esta ciencia está ahí está disponible
hay que aprovecharla hay que utilizarla
también para la educación para la
transmisión pero sobre todo hay que
dejar de destruir este patrimonio y
protegerlo y hay que tener los medios
financieros políticos y jurídicos para
hacerlo
por último usted también anunció la
creación de una plataforma digital en el
2024 siguiendo con esta perspectiva de
poner las herramientas digitales al
Servicio del patrimonio una especie de
Gran biblioteca que permitirá a todos
los habitantes del planeta acceder a los
más bellos tesoros de la humanidad es
una nueva forma de acceder al patrimonio
incluso a que en Grecia tienen una
experiencia donde utilizan la realidad
virtual para dar una imagen y una idea
de cómo eran estas ciudades antiguas en
su época de esplendor
por lo menos conocerlo hoy tener a
disposición todo el conjunto de planos
vistas poder acceder y visitar este
patrimonio incluso a distancia
acceder visite su patrimonio ya tuvimos
esa experiencia durante la pandemia de
covid donde estas eran las únicas
visitas accesibles
podemos tener una biblioteca digital a
la que todo el mundo pueda contribuir
que podría ser también algo muy
participativo y que nos permitiría tener
esta enciclopedia digital de los sitios
del patrimonio mundial
accesible para todos gracias directora
general de la UNESCO
gracias a ustedes Muchas gracias gracias
por habernos dado su visión del futuro
de un patrimonio mundial al servicio de
las personas como fuente de resiliencia
y sostenibilidad y gracias a ustedes por
habernos visto quédense con Franz 24 las
noticias continúan
[Música]